ولكن فيما يتعلق بفكرة
تجربتك الشخصية لكونك في الطرف المتلقي
لأمر التفتيش الفيدرالي هذا ، فأنا
أتساءل كيف تعتقد أن ترامب
يتفاعل شخصيًا مع بحث Mar-A-Lago على
وجه الخصوص بواسطة عملاء مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي ، فأنا
أعني أن هذا  حتى أنه يقترح أن
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي ربما يكون قد زرع دليلًا
لا يوجد دليل على الإطلاق حول
هذا
نعم وليس من المفترض أن يكونوا
الطرف الذي يحمي اللون الأزرق ، أقصد أن أجعل
الخير عبارة مثل
أنه متهور جدًا وهو [ __ ] جدًا أنا حقًا
لا ترغب حتى في إعطائها أي وقت على الهواء
لأنها مجرد خطأ من
جميع النواحي ولكن هناك شيء واحد بالنسبة
لدونالد المؤكد ليس بقدر القلق من أن
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي جاء إلى Mar-A-Lago ، فهو ليس
ما يقلقه هو أنه  يعرف ما هي
المعلومات الموجودة في الصناديق التي
تم أخذها وهذا ما
يثير قلقه إلى جانب من هو الذي كان
يقدم المعلومات لأنه
يشعر الآن بأنه محاصر ويشعر بأنه وحيد تمامًا
ويجب عليه أن يطلب  د تشعر بهذه الطريقة
لأنك مطمئنًا مهما كان الشخص
الذي زود السياج
بالمعلومات التي يرغب في تقديمها
أكثر وسيستمر في فعل ذلك
حتى النهاية وشيء واحد تعرفه
عندما يداهم الفدراليون عادةً ما يأتي
بعد ذلك هو لائحة اتهام
والسجن ولا أحد يعرف أنه
أفضل مني ،
هذا متشابك للغاية ، من الصعب
حقًا فرز كل شيء ، لكنني فعلت ذلك في
وقت سابق من هذا الأسبوع عندما اجتاح وكيل مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي
Mar-A-Lago وأنت تعلم أنه حصل على
كل هذه المعلومات و  كل شيء من
هذا القبيل كان لديك شعور
بأن الحكومة كانت تفعل شيئًا ما
كان من المستحيل على أي شخص آخر القيام به
وكان ذلك يخلق دونالد ترامب
كشخصية متعاطفة فجأة بدا
وكأنه سينتهي به كل هذه
القوى ولكن الآن عندما يذهب
وسيستغرق الأمر الخامس الذي تعرفه أنه عاد
إلى من كان غير متعاطف للغاية ،
تعلمون كثيرًا أنك تعرفين أرني
إخباري بالحقيقة حول ما
تفعله وأعتقد أنه  أفرط
يده هنا من خلال أخذ الخامس الذي تعرفه ،
فربما يوفر حماية
مؤقتة لبعض أفراد شعبه ، لكن في
النهاية سيتعين عليه أن يصبح نظيفًا في
بيئة أو أخرى وسيكون
أقوى بكثير إذا أخبرنا
ما يحدث حقًا ليس فقط في
mar-a-laga ولكن ما يحدث هنا
في هذه الجبهات الأخرى غير تلك الجبهات الأخرى
حتى نتمكن من إصدار حكم متزن في جميع أنحاء البلاد
، من
الصعب جدًا إصدار أحكام متوازنة
حول دونالد ترامب  لأنه
دائمًا ما يفاجئك كثيرًا ، فأنا
خائف من الجانب السلبي